visite de la mairie des mureaux
rencontre des policiers au commissariat
échanges avec des associations
intercultures east of castaner ministre
de l'intérieur présenté aux acteurs de
la ville les perspectives de la lutte
contre l'islamisme et le repli
communautaire dans le département
on commence à peine au niveau des liens
elle serait qu'on a déstabilisé un petit
peu certaines 3h et plus confiant parce
que je n'étais pas habitué des
patrouilles appuyée sur le secteur
nous avons vu que cette politique d'
entrave au développement de l'islamisme
a pu porter ses fruits au mur nous
l'avons constaté
et donc c'est cette méthode que nous
voulons renforcer ici aux mureaux mais
que nous voulons appliquer sur
l'ensemble du territoire national ne
faut pas croire que le risque de
développement de l'islamisme serait
cantonnée à quelques quartiers y compris
des quartiers qui n'ont plus rien à voir
avec l'image populaire que l'on ne peut
avoir comme les mureaux ici dont on a vu
que les mureaux de 2019 n'ont plus rien
à voir avec les mureaux de 2000 et donc
il est essentiel que nous nous
inspirions des bonnes pratiques de ce
travail mutualisé de tous les services
pour le ministre il faut faire de la
lutte communautariste et islamistes une
priorité 1900 emplois de policiers et
gendarmes seront dédiées sur le sujet et
les lieux culturels sportifs et
associatifs qui se radicalise qui seront
surveillés et fermé
le ministre a rappelé que l'islam a
toute sa place en france contrairement à
l'islamisme sachez que les musulmans
sont les premiers confrontés à ces
problématiques
sauf que nous visitons et dans le cadre
les choses nous avons précisé les
nuances smoothies dans le problème dans
sa solution parce qu'il faut le visiter
dans sa solution il faut pas dire que ça
ne va pas c'est à dire comment en
comment répond un certain nombre de
problèmes et de problématique à travers
une vision globale
une vision partagée avec un cahier des
charges exigeant une politique globale
d'accompagnement c'est ce que souhaite
christophe castaner pour les villes
sensibles les quartiers prioritaires
je pense que c'est bien que dans l'unité
républicaine nous promenions ce sujet à
bras le corps parce que il est en train
de fracturer une partie de notre pays et
tout cela n'est pas un très bon signe
que nous adressons à nos concitoyens une
expérimentation qui devrait donc
s'étendre dans les années à venir sur
tout le territoire